Let's see if we can come
up with the equations
for these different functions--
function A, B, C, and D.
And I encourage you to pause
the video right now and try it
on your own.
So it might jump out at you
that these all look a little
bit like y is equal to the
square root of x, which
would look something like this.
And we've covered this
in previous videos.
y equals the square root of
x looks something like this.
Except what we have here--
all the other things look
like at minimum we flipped
over the horizontal axis,
and at least for
B and D we flipped
over the horizontal
and vertical axis.
And in all the cases
we have shifted it.
So let's think about
how we do that.
So let's first flip over
the horizontal axis.
So where we would have
expected a positive y,
we're now going to
have a negative y.
So essentially we're
just going to do
y is equal to the
negative square root of x
to get this thing.
This is y is equal to the
negative square root of x.
So put that negative in
front of the radical.
We flipped it over
the horizontal axis.
So that is y is equal to the
negative square root of x.
Now let's think about how
we can shift this thing
to look like function
A. Well, there's
two things about function
A that are different.
It's shifted to the left by
3, and it's shifted up by 1.
And we've seen this
in previous examples.
If we want to get to
A-- so I could write
a of x-- what we could do
to shift to the left by 3,
we got to replace
our x with x plus 3.
So this is going to be negative
square root of x plus 3.
That shifted us to the left.
And then to shift
up, we just have
to add a 1 right over here.
So that right over
there is our a of x.
Now let's think about B of x.
And actually maybe I
should move on this side
so that I can clear my little
scribbles right over there.
So that is our A of x.
Now let's think about B of x.
How is B of x
different than A of x?
Well, B of x starts
at the same point,
but it's flipped over
the vertical line
x is equal to negative 3.
So its domain is different.
This function's
domain is defined
for x is greater than
or equal to negative 3.
B is defined for x is less
than or equal to negative 3.
And we saw that also
in the previous video.
What we need to do is flip
the sign of everything
that's under the radical.
So B of x is going to be equal
to the negative square root
of-- and going from A
of x to B of x, we're
going to flip the sign of
everything under the radical.
So it's negative x plus 3.
And then once again we have
the plus 1 right over there.
Now, to go from B of x to D of
x is reasonably straightforward.
We just have to change
how it's shifted.
D is shifted relative to
the original function.
It's shifted up by 3
and to the left by 1.
So D of x is going to
look very similar to B
of x except its shifting
is going to be different.
So let me just
write the part that
is going to be very
similar to D of x.
It's negative x plus something,
and then plus something.
D of x has been shifted--
relative to the square root
of x-- to the left by 1.
So this is going to be x plus
1 and it is shifted up by 3.
So it's going to be
plus 3 just like that.
And then finally C of x is just
like D of x, except everything
under the radical has to
have its sign flipped.
So it is going to be negative
square root of x plus 1 plus 3.
Another way to think
about it, if you wanted
to go from A of x to C of x,
they look very much the same
except their shifting
is different.
C of x is shifted up
by 3, instead of 1,
so that's that difference.
And it's shifted to
the left relative
to the square root of
x by 1, instead of 3.
So that's why we have x
plus 1, instead of x plus 3.
The one thing I
always want to stress,
it's very intuitive that
changing this value--
if you make this larger
you're going to shift it up.
If you make it smaller you're
going to shift it down.
But it's a little
counterintuitive
that when you make
this value larger
you're shifting
more to the left.
And when you make this value
smaller, or even negative,
you start shifting
more to the right.
And we go into this in some
depth in the previous video
where we kind of start
talking about all of this,
but it's just to think
about, especially
relative to square root of x,
when you think about just y is
equal to square root of
x, what makes y equal 0?
What has to happen
under the radical first
to be kind of at the starting
point right over here?
Well, everything under the
radical has to be equal to 0.
And so you could think about
that same thing over here.
To be at this starting point,
everything under our radical
has to be equal to 0.
When does everything
under our radical
equal 0 at x equal negative 1?
Well, if everything under
the radical was x plus 1.
So I encourage you to think
about that as deeply as you can
and to play around with
things, and then hopefully it
will start making a
little bit of sense.